unterwegs ist sie immer seit drei jahren
ist christine wolff aufsichtsrätin
mittlerweile bei sieben unternehmen vom
energieversorger bis hin zum baukonzern
zuvor hat sie als managerin in amerika
und asien gearbeitet dann die idee
aufsichtsrätin zu werden und die seiten
zu wechseln
alle zehn jahre überlegt man ja mal wie
es weitergeht und ich habe auch immer so
alle zehn jahre eigentlich eine
veränderung gehabt bin dann später ins
management gekommen und ja als ich so
jetzt die 50er ansteuerte dachte ich ja
ich möchte doch etwas anders machen und
zwar vorstände kontrollieren auch solche
in denen es zurzeit hoch her geht zum
beispiel bei hochtief
der internationale baukonzern hat ein
schwieriges jahr hinter sich und allein
in deutschland 1000 menschen entlassen
ganz ganz wichtig ist dass sie rückgrat
haben dass sie zu ihren entscheidungen
stehen dass sie unbequeme fragen stellen
dass sie nicht nervös werden wenn alle
anderen anderer meinung sind dass sie
sich einfach durchsetzen können dazu
gehört einfach ein starkes
selbstbewusstsein
meistens ist christine wolff mit männern
in aufsichtsräten
heute bereitet sie sich mit einem
kollegen auf eine sitzung bei einem
mittelständler vor frauen den deutschen
vorständen oder aufsichtsräten noch
lange keine selbstverständlichkeit dass
wir einfach ein druckmittel brauchten um
die situation was frauenanteil in
aufsichtsräten angeht zu verändern also
mit dieser freiwilligkeit es wäre schön
wenn sie etwas mehr frauen in ihre
aufsichtsräte holen würden oder in ihre
führungsetage
das hat ja nicht wirklich fast gebracht
international bisher ist jeder zehnte
aufsichtsrat in deutschland eine frau
bis 2016 sollen es dreimal soviel seien
nicht machbar meint dieser unternehmer
der im gegensatz zu christine wolff
gegen die quote ist das wird das wird
sich nicht von heute auf morgen ändern
und deshalb hab ich ganz stark die
befürchtung dass es zu fehlbesetzung
kommen wird es gibt haufenweise
qualifizierte frauen und ich muss sagen
dass auch nicht unbedingt die jetzigen
besetzung von männern den aufsichtsräten
immer so tipptopp sind das findet auch
der verband deutscher unternehmerinnen
hier haben die frauen lange auf die
quote gewartet und bieten seminare für
angehende aufsichtsrätinnen an 150
frauen haben sie schon ausgebildet
bislang so die präsidentin des verbandes
seien aufsichtsräte reine männer klicken
gewesen
es klappt sagt man ja auch immer also
ein wir haben mit vielen
personalberatern geredet und wir gehen
davon aus dass auch heute noch 15 bis
allenfalls 20 prozent wirklich
transparent sozusagen über personal
berater vermittelt werden und die
restlichen 70 80 eben durch netzwerk
frauen müssen in die bisherigen männer
netzwerke um an die guten jobs in der
industrie und in der verwaltung zu
kommen
sie hat es schon geschafft